you know and this is just a motion this
is uh this is the kind of show this is
very emotional this show they said it's
ignited with a bunch of passion a bunch
of love and stuff but it's dealing with
the truth too and dealing with the two
human beings and with the two for human
being the floor then you know we beat
ourselves up some time alright everybody
will welcome to another episode of hot
boxing i'm evan britain's and i'm mike
tyson oh yeah my brother awesome guest
today awesome guest we've got chris
cyborg in the house
nothing welcome my pleasure thank you
it's great to have you here with me from
Brazil I born in Brazil I live America
now a million years yes you like it here
yes is it place it then give you the
opportunity for me to show my job it's
nice really nice excellent where do you
live what nice that's awesome
well aside from being a UFC champion
you're also you've done a ton of
incredible work with fight for the
Forgotten and Justin Ren's organization
another UFC guy and tell us a little bit
about that I know you do a lot of great
work over in Africa with children and
helping people bring reefs bringing
resources to those areas so tell us a
little bit about that you know the first
thing I always like to tell my tell my
fans I'm out the champ a long time but
the most important be the champion the
people champion you know like make the
difference it's not just the champion
all the belt but make the difference and
I will do missionary work in Brazil and
this time I went to Uganda and very
special we think we help people to help
us cause you see a lot of things there
and have Mays experience and I work with
fight for golly we put like a into
village water well okay
and we went to that for celebrate to
water but very nice because you see like
you cannot complain about anything the
worst case in your life you hear is not
same there you know and they just okay I
was known I don't like to do videos
anything I do like this because a show I
want to show off no no I want to maybe
open the people how to do the same you
know and then I think work for just as
nice because the fight forgot because I
put the water and I went there see it
works because there's simply a lot of
things people complain okay but to help
but we don't see that you did or not you
know and and I gonna be for every
chamber for then for sure you know
they're gonna have clean water all the
time when they wake up this is the more
special yeah it's so important bring
clean water to yes don't have wait
because we really don't think have
people in the world having this problem
because we wake up every day I didn't
know I know you just turn on a faucet
yes yes good for granted I mean yeah um
I've been to UM South Africa before so
wait oh that's the way it goes oh wait
oh and I seen this little baby kid like
Mikey like seven years old and it's
playing with a giant pig around 500
pounds I pick a capable of eating that
kid is a vicious animal but he's playing
with it smacking it around jumping back
putting it ahead likes wrestling it and
I'm saying what a life and he lives in
shambles
he lives in shambles he lives like in
the tenth house when it's hot it must be
boiling in there and it's just no clean
water and he's ravish yes oh forget it
and this people are happy yes this is
true yeah you know I don't expect it if
you got like me and you we expect
something they don't expect anything
they're happy without any yes something
that we can never comprehend cuz we're
never yes we taught that way we never
took grateful we were always beaten into
submission and no gratitude you know you
know young age gratitude this is the one
thing changed like touch my heart
because when they look at the kids
they're then I have shoes I saw a girl
going to school she just is having one
like left size of shoes and they look
her I feel my heart like I want to cry
because I just
but then don't know on the other life it
didn't appreciate what they have and
look at then everybody smile it's true
yeah it's very great it's very nice yes
you know there's another grace and think
that I see kids they're very food kick
bit ones and ones naked one little snake
the place I went the water plays the
village we saw we filmed that and they
were saw the little kids
bad food cumin snakes stepping on oh wow
we forgot what that comes in yeah
so what you guys go and you dig water
wells what it's the other work that is
done on these trips I went to South
Africa place we went and then I have a
having good team there and then I'm
training there because I was thinking
I'm gonna fight in Brazil ok
may 11 and I went to set up for training
and you come and I hear about just are
gonna beat Uganda say no I want to go
with you and I always put the water and
it's ok if you come it will celebrate
and I did celebrate we visit the pygmies
because just as like the big the big
pygmies and the pygmies it's like it's
normal people but the people's more it
does more oh yeah I'm heard but never
seen where that freaked me out
some people are giants to the right
thumb track that a giant and it's crazy
because Justin leave it for there like
one year in Congo and the job and these
people we helped then then pass it to
the border in the jungle but past Uganda
and then the people put it in like it
some jail then can don't leave that then
put 300 now then 160 because out signals
IDs and a lot of bad things drink bad
water and when they went that will help
with this people but like in Congo have
like 400,000 pygmies and they all this
late because people don't see them like
people human being then think then any
more slaves yeah didn't live in Congo
and these people now in Uganda we help
then you're gonna help it inform teacher
then for him because that was a hunting
you live with the jungle and they're
gonna help y'all so gonna help it inform
with
the water the kids start sturdy like in
English they probably have the
independence 100 years yes if not even
last year did it yeah I probably had the
independence in the 60s or the 70s
probably maybe for something like that
in the Congo then they had what then
they had we D I mean he with the
dictator and they ravaged the country
and all that stuff yeah but you know the
girls did we help with newer ones and on
some people gonna help with you but nice
you're gonna give you because they don't
know another life to their hunting then
eat what they hunt and then now we're
gonna the kids start to learn English
there it's really cool we can talk to
the kids and they will now help the
village they're gonna help you form you
know let's change the life somebody
knows yeah that's amazing
yes that's amazing work I mean but we
never think you had people living this
to live in the jungle net these days
like they have tribe have never been in
contact with people yeah yeah that's
great I know I was afraid a little bit
yeah absolutely because you know sure I
start to read you I was in gonna start
to read I was weeping my knife recited
me and then pass and I know they're
gonna work a lot but you know my son
does what she does he um he goes to
Haiti and stuff and I had one time to my
son please don't good I would never go
to hell you know this and then I
understood um the blessings that you get
for going there my son's just the kiddie
16 he he doesn't know what he's doing
but he does know what he's don't get oh
wow
Africa with the Haiti whales the world's
and all that stuff fresh water
especially it's nice I mean we just get
so caught up in the rat race of life and
America you know like trying to make
money and trying to be successful and
you know trying to look good and all
this [ __ ] and we don't even stop to
think for a minute that there are people
across the world that don't even have
running water
yes you've got to walk miles to get
water
listen hey if you sent them a thousand
I'll do the left in my lifetime
yes okay mister $1,000
life dining you know what we've done
with $1,000 before all right a lifetime
$4,000 there'd be a ball over there yeah
okay that's good good because it's
awesome we care it's nice when you go
visit someplace because we stopped
believing in the bubble because some
people think they bubble never seen
anything think this or do we leave it's
the only disorder I have a lot of a lot
of things you know yeah I I imagine
that's an amazing lesson to see you know
like you were talking about you go there
and these people are living in such dire
conditions yet they're still finding
happiness I know well yeah that is such
a god shot yes where do they go to the
bathroom they have sewage system where
did they go in the woods
no no then because now then okay like
then they want a village it cannot get
out but then they make one hope it's a
one hole in the floor and they don't
have a restaurant in theme like like
then certain parts of Europe it like
that too
you just go somewhere as a hole in the
floor India's like yeah yeah that's
insane I mean we take our bathrooms for
granted - yeah that's crazy
do they have shamans and these like
villages or their home should they do
they invented this stuff pretty much are
they like village doctors who have like
traditional medicine the faith against
the widow I'm sure they do yeah waiter
has become like almost a tourist
attraction you know I want to see so
many Europeans in as in the middle of
the jungle
yeah I think that one over there then
the village then it like leaves some
leaves I think that leaves they make no
hungry interest and maybe happy yeah I'm
like I guess like what I'm asking is
like what's the medical access if
somebody needs like medical care and I
here does then die and oh no listen I'm
the disease whatever they have now only
thing they needed a shot
them right yeah yeah hey then they think
his little place is too big and now it's
not just the place I went to gun that's
a lot of please go on Congo right and
when I went to gun and I see I check it
out and then we see he's not the worst
place it's like a number seven then
imagine number one remember one whole
village is disease infected people
Muslim beacon now it's really bad after
all village man kids the kids deaf young
13 12 I've been attacked I'm molested
and the whole village is infected with
diseases yeah some of them believe if
they have sex with a virgin that this
disease would dissipate we disappear
that's some of the rumors yeah and then
in Congo have said Congress some people
believe you should then like have a
relationship sex to be fifty guineas big
on that court a JV you'll catch it yeah
like your friend yeah wow he must kill
them in the street yes yeah they mean
nothing to them yeah yeah bad stuff
that's Dutch bad stuff
how long have you guys known each other
have you met before and I have before
yeah
yes sandwich I went to your place in Las
Vegas yes yeah yes yeah we take a
picture together and I am i funny but we
take one picture together when did you
guys meet
man maybe two no far I think yeah I was
known in the FCS when I met you know I
met you at the fights too yeah yes yes
well tell us about your fighting career
Chris like how did you come into how did
you come to fighting you know I I never
want to be a fighter before like I don't
have a dream in anything and when I was
teenager might but my dad loved boxing
and he's always watched - Mike - Mike
fights and then his house I waited for
him for watch but I was a fall asleep
because in Brazil it's like 3 a.m. is
very late and but I never connect to the
fight but I always like to sport before
I do tracking field I play
and ball and more events on track
I do like it that low it's like a seven
okay
seven we do 200 meadows okay metres 100
metres 800 meters and I could to careful
yes seven because yes and we start I
started playing handball I play handball
like but everybody think his hand about
you think you playing the wall no no
it's a good real game yeah six again
takes a serious yes yeah and then
stacked of 12 and then play home I won
high school college and then when I was
in university I was playing handball and
this is like save me because I have a
scholarship I really want to be the best
what I'm doing
make me put out drugs out to do bad
things and when I was playing handball
University one guy saw me his black belt
for shooter box gym mmm-hmm and he told
after the game he say you know I think
it can be great fighter and he's give me
a give me a shoot the Box card I look at
him crazy and I'm not and because I have
bad bad bad situations when I go to
school I have my ass kick all time you
know I never think you're gonna be a
fighter and then look at him like me
okay and then all the time he saw me
University tell me you went to the gym
went to the gym okay one day I show up
to the gym and there was my tight ring i
watch and then i say maybe we can do
that I was strong but I have like
coordination for punch anybody and and
the one I did my first training it's
nice because when people punch me I
don't know much but I want to punch back
and then this is the one thing you
cannot teach people you can teach you
techniques you can teach you then you
know you can say this and what's the
first thing that happened when you got
punched in your face
how did you feel I won't punch back yeah
push back a like a you know Mickey anger
makes me angered and then okay I start
learning and then in three months
training I told my coach you know I
wanted one fight because I was complete
I come to race a I do handball and I
like to compete and challenge you'd like
compete and it's the milk race I'm gonna
see what can do for you
okay and then one month later he told me
Chris we gotta fight for you but have a
problem
he's know my tights Mamie you're gonna
have to learn little things come on
heifer okay cool
I didn't know I was 19 years old I was
the know wasn't gonna be a fight that
was going I'm stressed nothing and I did
my first fight I I was doing good but I
lost the first fight because in Brazil
in the event you can step on the face
when the people in the floor you can
step on the head yeah and the shitty box
very clear about this because in Pride
other events and then we train a lot and
then when is go steppin and then under
her head and the floor she push me and
then I fall and I dislocated my elbow
but I didn't mean I I was like I said
you know and after the fight I put my
albumen place and ask for rematch same
night and in my heart saying no I born
for this this is not have a right card I
can do whatever I want I born for this
and after this day I stopped doing
handball
I stopped running track and field and
just me me I love it
that's awesome story and that's because
I'm not looking for like something that
God put in my life you're a fighter
because and I felt my heart I bought for
this you know another sport just helped
me build Who I am
but yeah yes that's awesome Mike and I
talked about all that that all the time
see I wanted that's so strange after the
Custis planes the significance of being
this individual to champ every champ
then I read about them and then I wanted
to be these guys I read about their
lives and what they had in a glamorous
lives they had you know all the women
all the cardi thought all the parties
all the girls little cars or and yes wow
this guy like these guys didn't even
have lost obey or like jobs yeah and
this is what I want to be I want to be
like these guys yeah you know that's I
wonder you dedicate my life being like
these guys yeah me too man I remember
that feeling too but that's so funny
that you were like a woman because we
gonna you know have an example yeah like
Mike like is that the example look okay
I want to be like anyone was a heart
because this is one I did in my I did
cup of fights
Brazil and the one I have the / to
DeSimone fight in America and they see
how the cement these people like my job
yeah he's really job because in
beginning my career I trained at the gym
like only me to grow it's 40 guys yeah
and my mom don't agree she's yeah I want
you be dentist
I'm a dentist I told okay I'm not the
answer but I can take four to four you
know I love her but yeah and then and
then when I start I started a fight SMA
I born for this and then see the
opportunity America and they moved to
America for stay six months and they
almost ten years away yes awesome yes
that's so cool and I mean I'm sure you
feel like the universe has put you on
this path to now with where you're
traveling the world and helping people
yes then this is the one thing I think
you want God to bless you I think you
have to bless be somebody people yeah
because if you location do God choose
you bless you anyways if you don't have
money my bless to you the people around
you you know be happy motivate people
try changing to do your word you leave I
think when god bless you something
blessed people because why is gonna
bless you if you're not gonna do
anything you're gonna stuck in you okay
gonna change you're gonna get for
another person you know because I like
to use my platform for share my faith
for share motivate people do something
different make the difference and know
around you I think this is the most
special because champio is nice
you can have the belt but cannot get
held about forever you know I still like
10 to 13 years in the field but I know
in my heart before say you know champion
are gonna be for about to get be cheaper
paper lives be champ you know remind
about you what you did for sure that
place village I went there gonna be the
champ for then the mad you have a water
you know this is a special yeah you
never underestimate you know I know
you're saying to Nina can't be champion
forever but never underestimate the
power of the championship belt yes it
lives forever in people's minds yeah uhm
rather than some people's mind yes I
don't know I know that's true I don't
think it's right sometime but I can't
stop this is who it is
of what it is people's mind they always
make it may make you the Fox go to you
you need to use this plataform in US and
then absolutely I always remember you
people will always remember yeah yes
yeah absolutely
Mike's totally right about that I mean I
really look at my life now as whoever I
am I want to spread blessings to people
having positivity yes you know as much
if I can lift somebody up every day
everyone that I talk to that I mean if I
can just lift them up a little bit to be
a little bit better for themselves every
day it's like I'm like those are I'm
just giving it's giving people blessings
like you're talking about you know and
spirit gathers around that person to
help them rise and to lift their
vibration because of this were there are
people more bully bully bully people
chatter and then like like it you can
because everybody allow Instagram you
see you you know have the perfect body
you see a lot of teenage when suicide
because bully you know because like you
have to support in ya know you can
support somebody look close to you know
doesn't matter if no money but your
attitude you know you do and then I
bring one shirt because before a big for
both I am for I make the shirt like
Chris I work against words love one fun
action I send it to me and I useful a
little while but because the water we
make a plan and I feel my heart you know
maybe we can be against a word but we
can change the words you and they make
different I take out the diverse and
they put your change
I love that yeah I love it and having
the gift T for you guys thank you so
much together you can change yes word
some people that's so awesome thank you
now come Mike how do you feel about that
man tell me because I feel like you're
just mister spread the love these days
especially
like don't forget to ship out those
hoodies
[Music]
[Music]
what's up I'm not gonna get the hoodies
out in time man Evan I'm busy okay and
then photoshoot wait tight ship station
comm ship station right now
hotbox and listeners can try ship
station free for 60 days when you use
promo code hotbox them there's
absolutely no risk you can start your
free trial without even entering your
credit card info so use code hot box and
and get your ship together that ship
station dot-com I'm aware that a lot of
people next to me watch me and may look
up to me and think I'm a certain kind of
guy I'm I'm good guy but they have to
understand that I'm not worthy of praise
I think God is worthy of praise sure
they do these things they look at
YouTube and I see you guys have mike
tyson immortal mike tyson God and I'm
not worthy of that you're like hey stop
I know me you can think what you want
but I know not for somebody that worth
it appraised me anything now I'm always
just Mike
I were one of those people that worship
people because I had nothing man that
low I had to be the worship but nothing
somebody from nothing and I worship them
well I think you've seen that to the
utmost that anyone can do anything that
they want to do and when I did the total
last time mm-hmm what I did was um my
whole life is telling me that all my
when I die all I must do is apologize I
felt all the pain I have a cause for my
tea all the pain ever cause people and
my journey in this world
I didn't see anybody thought the pain I
couldn't no pilot I wasn't enough I was
so happy that I woke up you know well
it's beautiful that you can look at that
man
painful stuff now ugly stuff too told us
[ __ ] ugly stuff to put that realness
rain your faith I don't want to [ __ ] you
up I'm sorry [ __ ] this interviewer but
I'm saying that's my experience like oh
you know everybody do mistakes and then
but God know your heart and now in
fulfill your heart he's listening you
and then he's gonna forgive you the one
person can only hear me know it's hey
I'm doing it well know anything about
God you know I don't know anything about
God and then you you you did a lot of
good things and then you it sparked a
lot of people me myself like be the
champ a bit everybody and do your best
you can and you exempt for a lot of
people you know and looking like this
yeah I get my life like that you know
come now I'll never be forgiven you you
will God forgive everyone you swap her
heart for having God I believe I exist
no no he's my only 9 that I think I'm
somebody it's my ego my own self
love and now he loved you and then
before he born he knows you're gonna
born his nose everything you know and
okay because you say people know about
me some mistake you say because you
everybody look to you you know like me
if it doesn't mistake you're gonna be
ever seven page in the newspaper you
know but a lot of people who mistake all
the time but because because if they
don't see they're never day and then of
no famous you know like but if you're
polite forgot that you know where they
open your heart maybe you see don't open
for God because it didn't know you you
didn't know him but he know you he is
for gonna forgive you like I learned it
I follow him and then I believe we have
to pay for a friend you you got you can
pay I haven't paid enough I haven't paid
enough is death if I died tomorrow I've
won I have to write the world a check I
was never paid I have to pay for my sins
no no if it whooping heart to God yeah
forgive me
yeah he's gonna forgive you you know
you're gonna forgive you I I believe
this you know we you know gonna but it
have to be some action like what you
doing is action is not me a thing action
for forgiveness because I'm what are you
doing now what are you doing now this
read you you open your heart for sure
opening the heart a lot of people you
know and then change sometimes you for
people say you know I did a lot of
mistake and if you sorry there's not a
lot of people can do that if you're
doing this now because you special and
because you read you you can change your
life about doing this what are you doing
like you God give me a pretend now for
you can do this you doing you do
something cool hey yes because you whoop
her heart now some people know what
their heart maybe somebody now listen
the video cow somebody know forgive me
to think I did I'm sorry you know
because it touched some heart and then
this is this your portunity doing you
know it is amazing what you do you do
Europe her height a lot of people know
one eye open no I do it out of fear okay
I know I'm for my experience I know I'm
a wind-up app and some way I have to be
um questioned for this
you know it's gonna be a challenge you
know and then we're gonna be praying for
you thank you yes God guide you touch
your heart put the beautiful people in
our life and talk to you in it I'm gonna
be always be around if you need talk
mercy yes sure oh [ __ ]
can I say something you saying anything
I'd love for you to talk to me brother
you you had to go through all of that so
that you could change the world dude
well yeah I don't see that you don't
realize how many lives you're changing
saving because of who you are and what
you've been through and how you're
willing to speak about it now you know I
speak about now because I'm afraid I did
the told of the day and they do it in my
face nobody can judge you like but
people do you put us people with us but
no matter a lot to do didn't I change
anything only god can judge you because
the only one perfect you know and you
just need to forgive yourself yeah
because you're loved yeah yeah people
can forgive themselves - we do what I do
for myself I want to be I'm a
megalomaniac yeah forget myself I'm
[ __ ] perfect but the reality of it is
that you did something [ __ ] you
guys pay up yes this is my world that's
just what I'm experiencing now no no man
well I love you dude I love you as well
you know I don't know I don't know why
but it's like you're my brother angry I
am your brother I want to be your
brother and I mean that's what we had
together with succeeding as brothers and
striving his brothers you know and this
is just most this is uh this is a kind
of show this is very motion of this show
this it's ignited with a bunch of
passion a bunch of love and stuff but
it's dealing with the truth too and
dealing with the truth of human beings
and but the true for human beings were
floor then you know we beat ourselves up
some time and sometimes we have to
forgive ourselves and loves us love
ourselves regardless stuff you gotta be
um maybe for ourselves as well maybe you
remember just the things you think it'd
be the bad things but you do where you
come from and then what you did first
fort you you in a lot of teenaged mind
you know like a lot of people maybe came
through a lot of things you've gone on
before in your life and as you know Mike
Tyson did his being champion he's did
fight great I can do that if he did I
can do that you know
and that you can you know he couldn't be
mad at yourself will you he God can
forgive anybody who just open your heart
you are doing you know and this is the
more specialty well I don't know um I
just the world I'm trying to is we are
we examine myself you know I mean I do I
don't know what do you call it
and you annually resource of myself and
I check myself out and sometimes you
know life is difficult even live you
know my life is pretty difficult and
after and then besides I mean just will
you have to be responsible individual
have to be established so for your
children and your family and your wife
and everything and like some time and
come fast at me come real fast
yes sorry about that Chris no I'm really
happy you know I was I believe like
there's nothing happened for no reason
no this is a good yes this is just
dealing with the realness
you know and then another thing but I
think bad things is if you happen our
life I think for changing you know God
change you make you better know
everything you pass through for sure
make you better you better than before
what food yes I have a great support
system family and yes and now it this is
a good thing you know I will don't
remember about this but the one time I
fell dropping and I feel very sad people
judge me people I say a lot of things
but the only people know who you are if
you use your shoes and they're never
gonna feel this and a lot of people
judge me a lot of people give back from
me and I have some days I'm in my room I
was crying because people judge you and
do you know and then say but after
passed everything through God just
changed making me better you know I I
don't feel bad about that happen but I
feel I feel bad that I'm a better person
before you know and this has happened
like once something bad happen your life
like you have to see you okay what I
need to learn from this for sure you
learned a lot of things you know a
different mic and and this is the most
special you know like it their life
happy stuff at first but for we cannot
quit we have to continue and use this
for changes I agree my own self
inventory you know do my self interests
so are the back saying I wasn't question
you did that today yeah you know yes you
have to do that - so what's your diet
like how do you eat you know hours I
have to
I walk who's not usually 70 75 kilos 77
but I thought more 45 you're like six
six kilos and I usually like to stay on
eat healthy all the time
vegetable someone I I know it I don't
like too much fast food you know
sometimes like after fight you died long
time you know but to really might have
my money helpful clean healthy and then
with very clean like clean like
vegetables salad fish and for keeping my
weight low no no because if I started
eating I'm gonna the kilos easy I was
when I was a fighter I would after fight
like you said I will go to eat and drink
every anything everything eat drink yeah
everything like a priest right so I have
to always lose from 260 to go down to 17
damn my homeboys doing a six-week poem
six weeks six weeks yeah nice I have to
I need I need the legs
810 weeks yeah six seven weeks yes
that's hard
yeah nothing the water nothing pretty
much pretty much a vegan so a lot of
faster doing a lot of fat and I spawn a
lot of running not sprinting a nine
exercise you just didn't yeah destroying
ready for war yeah you're getting focus
when you have a fight you Fox Run tank
and the help you don't have a lot of
food you can keep new folks nice no
doubt man Chris is there anything that
you want to shout out before we wrap
this thing up and one people not to get
into contact with you yeah you know go
my Instagram Chris I bore you fun to
know about fight for garden you can go
my my website by ciphered fight for
garden for lifting for god yeah fight
for the you can go my website Chris
Cybercom and we'll throw all that stuff
in the show notes yes and I have my pink
Buffy's the last week I doing like for
to help woman's with trainee I share my
experience like I'm a fighter show
leader be max of mixed martial arts for
then help then for self-defense
unless a think for the girls and all the
help my team if you want my shirts
change yours and the blue one like us no
yeah go to my website and I just say
thank you and my youtube to you guys can
check also I will invest in my youtube
because people usually sometimes see me
they say met me the secret you will nice
I say how's your thinking what I am
people call it what I fighting these
people would never come near me before
they know me now you know I believe I'm
talking to you is that your [ __ ] evil
I mean I know and then the people say
are you really nice to see me I cannot
be like it or not KJ KJ I'm there for
war I know like you am I gonna die and
but it's nice because YouTube it can
show little be Who I am the real like no
I'm seriously gonna kill somebody by now
you smile you're beautiful
yeah and then and then because my
nickname to cyborg and the pizza this
girl not have hard she's ever no I have
a hard heart and and it isn't YouTube
channel and then say thank you for you
guys for they have the opportunity I
feel very blessed to be here and talk to
you that mic amazing spirit and if I
spoke with you as well yes and I mean
you know I mean I'm merely happy bu you
example for a lot of teenagers a lot of
kids and I'm a example for me and I just
say blasphemy here thank you guys thank
you so much
nice thanks Mike no thank you buddy hit
for athlete with that about this is one
of our shirt yeah oh yeah I like that
cannabis baby safe protect the brain
he's to check the brain THC CBD
neuroprotective baby
alright everybody well that was a
[ __ ] wacky one until next time I'm
Evan Britain I'm Mike Tyson your side
we're out of here everybody thanks
[Music]